first question what are we pricing in
here and I know that's a difficult
question but when you see an eighteen
percent drop followed up by a full five
percent drop this morning what are we
pricing in here the fines or something
much much bigger well we've now we've
now eliminated about 15 billion euros of
market cap right in the US the EPA is
talking about a maximum potential fine
of up to 18 billion dollars roughly so
we're pricing that in I think we don't
really price in any contagion effects
into other regions or you know engines
outside of the diesel range so it's
still early days the market is very
nervous here we don't have enough
details we don't even know whether this
has major implications on management
within folks well do we know for sure
and can we ever know for sure that this
was just the United States well it seems
like it to me because the US has the
strictest NOx emissions globally in the
u.s. comics have to comply with 31
milligram per kilometre compared to 80
milligram in Europe so it makes it
incredibly hard to comply with diesel
engines in the US that's why the market
share of diesel is only 0.8 percent over
there it's more than fifty percent in
Europe and VW is an especial situation
because they've been really pushing
smaller engines and smaller cars into
the market and you know investing all
the money for technologies and small
cars you know gets you to the edge of
making any money with these products the
other big question is how much worse
this could possibly get for management
Vince a corn will he get a contract
extension will he won't see and then
we'll do this should he should he
shouldn't he will he well I think it's
almost impossible for a supervisory
board to renew or extend the contract in
a situation like this it's totally
unclear who knew what within the company
if management knew that this was going
on which could well be the case then I
think the CEO can't remain in his post
so I take it from you that he shouldn't
remain will they allow him to remain as
far as you're concerned well I think
this is about really the supervisory
board with this that's the highest group
of people the control management
they're keeping their face we have
politicians sitting on their from Lower
Saxony I think it's it's very very
difficult for these people to stick to
someone who at the end is the chief
engineer within the group and who has to
take responsibility if you know if
things should have been known well aware
within the company this is a company
that spent an absolute fortune on
research and development in the hat to
cheat I've heard some people call this
the Lance Armstrong moment for the car
industry the LIBOR moment for the
automotive industry do you think there
is a case of brand contagion nevermind
Volkswagen this becomes an industry
issue very quickly well firstly VW is
investing more in rd than any other
company globally in any sector so you're
right if they can't afford it how could
anyone else but they've been in the
special situation they dominate more
than fifty percent of the u.s. diesel
market and I think it's really isolated
to focus right now the next big thing in
Europe will be that Europe will change
the test cycles for diesel engines from
2017 to a real-world testing of these
cars and that will then make it more
difficult for European companies to
comply so it's a neverending story the
companies in the automotive industry
have to invest more on powertrain
technologies which at the end of the day
is good news for suppliers but bad news
for OEMs final question for you on we
have wiped out almost 17 billion euros
off the market cap of Volkswagen we're
down almost twenty two percent over the
last two days what does this mean for
your price target can you even have a
price target on this company right now
well in these situations is really tough
for an endless right I have a buy on the
stock so it's it's it's very tough and
it's even tougher for shareholders that
are invested we have no clarity what's
going to happen here we really ask
management to come up with a plan and
and to take the right consequences in
management folks wrong is a big change
over story it's a restructuring story
we've had these turmoils and management
the battle between the Chairman at the
CEO all of this year all this stuff
really has to come to an end in the
interest of their workers their
shareholders and their customers and
this is obviously now extremely painful
here the final question I just want to
get a bit of insight into the life of an
analyst
the news like this drops over the
weekend you've got to buy on the stock
and you maintain a buy on the stock how
do you do that aren't what is the
thought process behind that well you
know you get into the office Monday
morning and the stock will be down you
don't know whether it's going to be ten
percent or twenty percent and you gotta
ask yourself well is this now an
interesting entry point or you know to
have to completely revise my my
investment case so my investment case on
folks wagon is that they will use this
momentum this year to change management
restructure the company I think they've
hired a great guy to run the VW brand
with mr. D's from BMW so I do think VW
is a turnaround story with all these
turnaround stories you have ups and
downs this is an extreme one but I
decided to stick to it because I do
think that they will get direct together